Hi, my name is Joel.
嗨，我叫乔尔。
I'm from New York City and I just wanted to call to make the case that the saluting joke is actually my joke, not Alex joke.
我来自纽约市，我打这个电话只是想证明，那个敬礼的笑话其实是我的，而不是亚历克斯的。
Now, my defense for that is twofold.
对此，我的辩护有两点。
Personally, Alec and I have been best friends since we were five and when asked recently, he couldn't quite remember whose joke it was while I definitely remember that it was my joke.
首先，我和亚力克从五岁起就是最好的朋友，不久前当被问及此事时，他记不清那是谁的笑话了，而我绝对记得那是我的笑话。
Secondly, ever since I've known him, Alex's record of being wrong about things has been unparalleled.
其次，自从我认识他以来，亚历克斯在各种事情上出错的记录一直是无与伦比的。
And I think those two things taken together definitively make the case.
我认为这两点结合起来，绝对可以证明这一点。
Either way, this was a joke that Alec and I used to make to each other all the time.
不管怎样，这是我和亚力克以前经常开的一个玩笑。
And Craig, our friend, dutifully asked if he could use it on the show.
我们的朋友克雷格尽职尽责地问他是否可以在节目里用这个笑话。
And I appreciate that he did because I think that this will be my lasting legacy and it will be how my children remember me when I'm gone.
我很感激他这么做了，因为我认为这将是我永恒的遗产，也将是我不在了以后我的孩子们记住我的方式。
So thanks for putting it on the show.
所以谢谢你们把它放到节目里。
Bye.
再见。
Oh, we'll be soon in New York City when I see you.
哦，我们很快就会在纽约市见面。
Please permit me to tell you everything in York City.
请允许我把纽约市的一切都告诉你。
Welcome to how we made your mother.
欢迎收听《我们是如何创造你母亲的》。
I'm Josh.
我是乔什。
We're out here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我们和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Say Craig.
打个招呼吧，克雷格。
Josh, tell us what we just heard from Alec.
乔什，给我们讲讲刚才我们听到的亚力克的录音是怎么回事。
That was your childhood best friend Joel.
那是你从小到大的挚友乔尔。
That is, that was Joel, my friend since, since we were four, five, six years old.
那是，那是乔尔，我从四五六岁起的朋友。
I went to elementary school, middle school, high school, and college together.
我们一起上过小学、初中、高中和大学。
High school was where he learned the saluting joke for me.
他在高中时从我这里学到了那个敬礼的笑话。
Alec, I got to say, it is so generous of you to have acquired that recording and to have played it rather than just flushing it down the toilet.
亚力克，我得说，你能弄到这段录音并把它放出来，而不是直接把它冲进马桶里，真是太大方了。
You're giving equal time to the other point of view.
你给了另一种观点平等的表达机会。
You guys, so just to give a backstory, we had dinner with Joel a few months ago, Alec and I.
伙计们，交代一下背景，几个月前我和亚力克跟乔尔一起吃了晚饭。
And this got pretty heated at the dinner because Joel was not happy.
晚饭时气氛变得相当白热化，因为乔尔很不高兴。
He was like, he's so convinced it's his joke and you have been so convinced for so long it's your joke.
他当时就觉得，他深信那是他的笑话，而你这么长时间以来也一直深信那是你的笑话。
And I of course borrowed this joke.
我当然借用了这个笑话。
I did ask permission for this one and I put it into this episode.
我确实为这个征求过许可，并且把它放进了这一集里。
I think I did.
我想我这么做了。
Didn't I?
我没有吗？
Goddamn it.
该死的。
Okay.
好吧。
We'll get to put a pen in that.
我们先把这个搁置一下。
Put a pen in that.
先把这个记下。
You are, you're a big man.
你真是个大度的人。
It's big of you to put this in because I am convinced that you're convinced it's your joke.
你能把这个放进来真是太难得了，因为我相信你确信那是你的笑话。
I'm a hundred percent sure.
我百分之百确定。
I'm a hundred percent sure it's not a bit.
我百分之百确定这不是在开玩笑。
You really think it's your joke?
你真的觉得那是你的笑话？
I definitely think it's my joke.
我绝对认为那是我的笑话。
And I'm just a few words of defense and then I'm gonna go away.
我只为自己辩护几句，然后我就不说了。
First is it's just the amount of childish and annoying that sounds like it would come from me.
首先是那种幼稚和讨厌的程度，听起来就像我会做的事。
That feels like that's my over.
感觉这就是我的风格。
That was your territory in the friendship.
那是你们友谊中的你的领地。
It was.
是的。
It's your brand?
这是你的个人标志？
Yes.
是的。
It's still your brand, by the way.
顺便说一句，这依然是你的标志。
It's kind of still your brand.
这在某种程度上依然是你的标志。
I think we all know actually the Joel when he believes in something, the vociferousness, which he fights for, is strong.
我觉得我们大家都知道，实际上乔尔一旦相信了什么，他那种据理力争的嗓门和气势是非常强烈的。
It doesn't mean he's more right.
这并不意味着他是对的。
He just, he leans in, right?
他只是，他很坚持，对吧？
He will agree with that.
他会同意这一点的。
I will agree with that.
我会同意这一点的。
I will say, but how long do you think you were when you came up?
我想说，但你们觉得自己是什么时候想出来的？
What age were you both when this joke magically was given to you by the gods?
你们俩多大时，这个笑话像魔法一样被上帝赐予了你们？
That's the best way we came up with that.
这是我们想出的最好的说法。
I came up with this in late high school, I want to say, pretty late high school.
我想我是在高中快毕业时想出这个的，我想说是高中非常靠后的阶段。
And then I want to also, to the court, if it pleased the court, Joel did make two mistakes in his little message, which I think just eliminates his entire argument.
然后我还想向法庭指出——如果法庭不介意的话——乔尔在他的小留言里犯了两个错误，我认为这直接推翻了他所有的论点。
One is that he said that he skipped over Craig the part where you were a huge part of this.
一个是他说他略过了克雷格，也就是你在这个笑话中扮演重要角色的部分。
He just went from he and I were using it to and then Craig's permission, which I think was rude because you were very much a part of the saluting culture.
他直接从“他和我在用这个”跳到了“然后得到了克雷格的允许”，我觉得这很粗鲁，因为你很大程度上也是这个敬礼文化的一部分。
He's a dog with a bone, he's making his case, but we all went to college together to Western University for four years and we did this joke, we came up with variations and it became part of our shared vernacular.
他就像对一根骨头死缠烂打的狗一样在辩护，但我们四个人一起在西安大略大学上了四年大学，我们编了这个笑话，想出了各种变体，它成了我们共同日常用语的一部分。
I actually think I came up with that, I think it was my joke, I think I invented it in college.
我其实觉得是我想出来的，我觉得这是我的笑话，我觉得是我在大学里发明的。
It's fun.
这挺好玩的。
And then the other thing was you did not ask permission for this.
然后另一件事是，你并没有为此征得同意。
Oh fuck.
噢操。
And which is fine, I don't mind that, I just like that it showed that Joel is wrong about Yet another thing I believe what happened like days before I want to be angel on that one though I hate to tell you why I think Joe's right about that that didn't happen You just told me that it was coming up and I was thrilled Okay, so I told I gave you a heads up like hey, there's something you're gonna like in this episode Okay, so I see that's what I mean.
这其实也无所谓，我并不介意，我只是觉得这表明乔尔在另一件事上也错了。我相信事情发生时大概是在几天前……我在这事上倒想当个天使，虽然我讨厌告诉你为什么我认为乔尔在这点上是对的，那事并没有发生。你只是告诉我这事要播了，我当时兴奋极了。好吧，所以我告诉你了，我给你打了个招呼，比如，嘿，这集里有个你会喜欢的东西。好吧，所以你看，这就是我的意思。
I knew I did something I did here's the real thing if this was a throwaway joke that appeared once on how I met your mother and no one ever mentioned Again, we would know one would be you be running from this joke over ownership, is because it is entered, it is in the bloodstream of every how I met your mother fan, like the major general colonel salute.
我知道我做了某事，我这么做了：真正的情况是，如果这只是一个在《老爸老妈浪漫史》中出现过一次、之后再也没人提过的废弃笑话，根本不会有人为了所有权而对这个笑话争抢不休。正是因为它已经渗入并存在于每一个《老爸老妈浪漫史》粉丝的血液中，就像那个少将上校敬礼一样。
That starts this episode, by the way.
顺便说一句，这正是这一集的开端。
This is, we're talking about Slapsgiving, which is episode nine of season three.
这就是我们谈论的“感恩节扇耳光”，也就是第三季第九集。
And I'll tell you when this, when the cold open starts, and this joke between Ted and Robin is introduced, Jordan and my wife said to me, oh, this is the, like she knew this joke, because we obviously, we do this every week.
而且我告诉你们，当冷开场开始、泰德和罗宾之间的这个笑话被引入时，乔丹和我妻子对我说，哦，这就是……就像她知道这个笑话一样，因为我们显然每周都在玩这个。
This is the origin.
这就是起源。
This is the origin she was so happy to learn it.
这就是起源，她知道后高兴坏了。
And I will also say that, remember, we talked in season one, we got a great, unbelievable note from someone who it's going through like a 36-hour labor.
我还要说的是，还记得我们在第一季时说过吗，我们收到了一条非常棒、令人难以置信的留言，来自一个正在经历36小时分娩的人。
And right before the kid, there was a couple that loved how I met your mother.
就在孩子出生前，有一对情侣非常喜欢《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
And the OBGYN said, "'Push, you're having a major contraction."
妇产科医生说：“用力，你正在经历一次强烈的宫缩。”
And she turned to her husband and gave us a loot, right before her baby was born.
她转过头看着丈夫，向我们敬了个礼，就在她的宝宝出生前。
That's the greatest use in history.
那是历史上最棒的应用。
That's the greatest recorded use of that, right?
那是对此类梗最棒的实录应用，对吧？
Now, if women were not saluting on the birthing table, is that what you call it, in the room where their child was born, neither you nor Joel would be having this argument.
如果女人们没有在产床上——你管这叫什么，在孩子出生的房间里——敬礼，你和乔尔都不会有这场争论。
I'll tell you how deeply woven in.
我来告诉你它融入得有多深。
Once you get it in your head and you listeners, sweet listeners, you know that once you get this in your head, you see it everywhere.
一旦你把它记在脑子里，还有你们这些听众，亲爱的听众们，你们知道一旦你脑子里有了这个概念，你到处都能看到它。
Just this morning, I almost emailed you, Craig, this morning, when I figured we would talk about it on the air.
就在今天早上，我差点给你发邮件，克雷格，就在今天早上，当时我想我们会在节目里谈论这个。
Did you see Pope Leo put out a big thing about AI, 42,000 words.
你看到教皇利奥发表了一篇关于人工智能的长文吗，42000字。
The New York Times says, Pope Leo's major new teaching on safeguarding humanity in the age of artificial intelligence is a forward looking document.
《纽约时报》说，教皇利奥关于在人工智能时代维护人类安全的重要新教导是一份具有前瞻性的文件。
And of course I went major new teaching as they started humanity in the age of artificial intelligence.
当然，当他们开始探讨人工智能时代的人类时，我觉得这是“重要的全新教导”。
It really is like once it's in your bloodstream, it's very hard to unwind.
这真的就像一旦它进入你的血液，就很难清除了。
It's a very sticky joke.
这是一个非常洗脑的笑话。
That's what I think.
我是这么觉得的。
I think just, I'm gonna give you a little bit of support here, Alec, because I did, I think in another episode of this show, and I'm not gonna tell the story again, in another podcast episode, I told the story of Joel and I having a days-long battle about whether the world's strongest man competition on ESPN2 was from the late 1970s, or was current to that day.
我觉得，我来给你一点支持，亚历克，因为我确实——我想在本节目的另一期中，我不会再讲这个故事了——在另一个播客节目中，我讲过我和乔尔为了ESPN2上的世界大力士比赛究竟是1970年代末的还是当天的，而进行长达数天的争论的故事。
And we had like a 72-hour argument about it where that ended with me saying I would throw myself off the roof of the campus center if I was wrong.
我们为此争论了大约72个小时，最后我说如果我错了，我就从校园中心的屋顶上跳下去。
And it turned out, and then we turned it on that night and it comes on again.
结果证明，然后我们那天晚上打开电视，它又播出了。
It was like in reruns again, it came on, a little cairon came out and said like, 1978, I look at Joel just waiting for an apology.
就像是在重播一样，它又播出了，屏幕下方弹出一个小字幕，上面写着：1978年，我看着乔尔，等着他道歉。
He just goes, okay, yeah.
他只是说，好吧，行。
And just walked out of the room.
然后就走出了房间。
It was a marathon argument.
那是一场马拉松式的争论。
Well, it's also encapsulates, what we're doing right now is a very, how I made one other thing, which is like the fallibility of memory.
嗯，这也概括了我们现在正在做的事情，非常符合《老爸老妈浪漫史》的另一个特点，那就是记忆的不可靠性。
Fallibility of memory, you know.
记忆的不可靠性，你知道的。
Especially Joel's, yeah.
尤其是乔尔的，对吧。
Yeah.
是的。
And in some ways, especially Joel's.
在某些方面，尤其是乔尔的。
This is why he didn't invite him on in person, because he would be, he would not be having this.
这就是为什么他没有邀请他本人来，因为他会，他根本受不了这个。
If you're talking about a long winding story, like you have to crowdsource that.
如果你在谈论一个漫长曲折的故事，比如你必须通过众包来完成。
Like it's very difficult.
就像这非常困难。
I just read this thing, Mary Carr said about her memoir, The Liars Club, like it's not, memoir is not historical.
我刚刚读到玛丽·卡尔（Mary Carr）关于她的回忆录《骗子俱乐部》（The Liars Club）的一段话，回忆录不是历史。
Like it's not a recreated fiction.
它不是重新创作的小说。
Like it is a partisan undertaking.
它是一项带有偏见的行动。
Like it is a, you know, there is an agenda going on.
它有，你知道的，它有一种意图在里面。
There are things left out.
有些事情被忽略了。
There are things amped up and amplified.
有些事情被夸大和放大了。
Like it's very tricky to recreate anything.
重现任何事情都非常棘手。
Yes.
是的。
And Huna, I mean, okay, we'll say we'll say we'll never know.
还有胡娜，我的意思是，好吧，我们只能说我们永远不会知道了。
With a slight 51% answer, Alex.
带着微弱的 51% 的答案，亚历克斯。
Yeah, good, yeah.
对，很好，对。
So much love to Joel to be with us.
非常感谢乔尔能和我们在一起。
Before we get into this episode of Slapsgiving, which I actually really loved.
在我们进入这集“感恩节大耳光”之前，其实我真的很喜欢这集。
I thought this was like a pop shelf, how I met your mother episode.
我觉得这就像是一部极棒的《老爸老妈浪漫史》单集。
I love this one of the best episodes of season three, certainly like maybe top 20.
我超喜欢这集，绝对是第三季最好的单集之一，或许可以排进前20。
It's an all-timey.
这是一部经典。
It's really good.
真的很棒。
It's an all-timey.
这是一部经典。
It's really good.
真的很棒。
But I just wanted to do some housekeeping in terms of schedule, just an update for people who are just on the edge of their seat, are Craig and Josh ever gonna have dinner.
但我只是想处理一些日常事务，关于日程安排，给那些翘首以盼、急切想知道克雷格和乔什到底会不会一起吃晚饭的人们一个更新。
We just wanna report just with great relief and great joy that it happened.
我们只想带着极大的宽慰和喜悦宣布，这事儿成了。
Thank God.
谢天谢地。
It happened.
成了。
It took four months, three and a half months to four months.
花了四个月，三个半月到四个月。
We had a delightful, delightful dinner at Romans in a beautiful, beautiful dinner.
我们在罗曼餐厅享用了一顿非常非常愉快的晚餐。
Delicious, shout out to Romans.
太美味了，向罗曼餐厅致敬。
Yeah, it was delicious and I learned how great Fort Green is in Brooklyn.
对，太美味了，而且我了解到布鲁克林的格林堡有多棒。
You were stunned.
你惊呆了。
I couldn't believe it was the greatest.
我简直不敢相信，太棒了。
It was the greatest.
太棒了。
We walked Nelson, Nelson, who sometimes cameos, Josh's dog, sometimes cameos on the pod over Josh's shoulder, looking out the window longingly to wanting to go on the walk that I've now been on with him.
我们遛了纳尔逊，纳尔逊偶尔会客串，乔什的狗狗，有时会在播客里出现在乔什的肩膀后面，渴望地看着窗外，想去散步，而我现在已经带它去过那条步道了。
And it is a lovely walk.
那真是一条宜人的散步路线。
It's that is a gorgeous area.
那个区域真是太美了。
I really had never spent any time there.
我以前真的从来没在那里呆过。
It was just, in the two blocks around you was like 18 great spots to go out from.
就在你周围的那两个街区里，大概有18个适合出游的绝佳地点。
I know, I kept pointing out, like, each restaurant that was on last.
我知道，我一直在指出，最后出现的每一家餐厅。
Well, I think Manhattanites, certain ones, like you, Craig, you're just, you're sleeping on Brooklyn.
嗯，我想曼哈顿人，某些人，比如你，克雷格，你对布鲁克林一无所知。
We're snobs, we are snobs, I know.
我们是势利眼，我们就是势利眼，我知道。
Yeah, it's not the 1990s anymore, my friend.
对，老兄，现在已经不是1990年代了。
I wonder if, we never said what part of Brooklyn Kobe was in.
我在想，我们从未说过罗宾在布鲁克林的什么地方。
I don't think maybe she, maybe she was friend of Fort Crane.
我不觉得，也许她，也许她离格林堡很近。
Maybe look at that Kobe, Robin, the character's name.
也许看那个，罗宾，那个角色的名字。
Yeah.
对。
Okay.
好吧。
But we had a great dinner.
不过我们吃了一顿很棒的晚餐。
We had a great dinner.
我们吃了一顿很棒的晚餐。
Craig, around the dessert line, Craig got very amorous with you.
克雷格，大约在甜点环节，克雷格对你变得非常多情。
I got very amorous, a little handsy.
我变得非常多情，有点动手动脚。
A little handsy.
有点动手动脚。
We had a great time.
我们度过了一段美好的时光。
glad we were able to make that work.
很高兴我们能促成那次聚会。
Also, I just got back from Rio, where my wife's brother, Gabe, got married to his beloved Isa in Rio.
另外，我刚从里约热内卢回来，我妻子的哥哥盖布在那里娶了他心爱的伊萨。
Congrats.
恭喜。
And what a destination wedding.
真是个绝佳的目的地婚礼。
Why not?
为什么不呢？
We couldn't miss it.
我们不能错过。
And we took our son who did as well as a seven month old could do, you know, this long.
我们带上了我们的儿子，他表现得和一个七个月大的婴儿所能做到的最好的一样好，你知道的，这么长时间。
How long is that play?
那趟行程有多长？
Well, first we connected through Atlanta and then flew to Rio and on the way back we flew Rio to Miami.
嗯，我们先经亚特兰大转机，然后飞往里约，回程时我们从里约飞往迈阿密。
They were, you know, the long stretches were nine, ten hours, but he did great.
你知道的，长途飞行段有九、十个小时，但他表现得很棒。
We're really happy to be home, but I have to say two things about this Rio wedding.
我们真的很高兴回到家里，但我必须对这场里约婚礼说两件事。
One, I love Brazil.
第一，我爱巴西。
It was my third time there.
这是我第三次去那里。
Let's go out to the Brazilian fans of our mother.
向《老爸老妈浪漫史》的巴西粉丝们问好。
I met a lot of Brazilian fans of the show, but I also have to say our friend Alex is married to a Brazilian woman named Luana, they're very dear friends of ours, and they split their time between New York and Rio, and they said, our nanny is the best down there.
我遇到了很多这部剧的巴西粉丝，但我还必须说，我们的朋友亚历克斯娶了一位名叫卢娜的巴西妻子，他们是我们非常亲爱的朋友，他们把时间分配在纽约和里约，他们说，我们在那里的保姆是最好的。
Like you've got, we needed some, you know, assistance so we could, you know, go places.
就像你们需要的，我们需要一些，你知道的，协助，这样我们才能，你知道的，去一些地方。
So Isabella, this wonderful, wonderful nanny down in Rio was watching our son for a part of the time.
所以伊莎贝拉，里约这位非常非常棒的保姆，有一段时间在帮我们照顾儿子。
We got immediately, like we were there six days.
我们立刻就，就像我们在那里呆了六天。
We felt so close to her, but when we were leaving, she said, Josh, can I, can I say one thing too?
我们觉得和她太亲近了，但当我们离开时，她说，乔什，我能，我能说一件事吗？
And I said, sure.
我说，当然。
And she said, I love your show.
她说，我喜欢你们的节目。
I learned English from watching your show.
我是通过看你们的节目学会英语的。
And I was such an honor to meet you and work with you this weekend.
这个周末能见到你并和你一起工作，我感到非常荣幸。
It was just so sweet.
真的太暖心了。
So shout out to Isabella.
向伊莎贝拉致敬。
She always said it at the very end.
她总是在最后才说。
She said it at the very end, very idea.
她是在最后才说的，太有创意了。
That's also very cool somehow.
不知怎的这也超级酷。
Very sweet, very sweet.
太暖心了，太暖心了。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我为你写了这段小曲子，要在纽约唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目中。
Hey, Greg, since we had dinner, any life updates?
嘿，格雷格，自从我们吃过晚饭后，有什么生活近况吗？
Oh boy, any life updates?
哦天哪，有什么生活近况吗？
Let me think, the dinner was the highlight of my fucking month, are you kidding?
让我想想，那顿晚餐是我他妈这个月的高光时刻，你在开玩笑吗？
That was it.
就是这样。
Now my daughter's playing saxophone, my son's playing the drums, we got a big salads concert for Hamish and Mother coming up on June 20th, but this will probably be long over.
现在我女儿在吹萨克斯，我儿子在打鼓，我们即将在6月20日为哈米什和母亲举办一场大型沙拉音乐会，但这到那时候可能早就结束了。
That will be long over by the time this happens.
等这期节目播出时，那早就结束了。
But yeah, the music thing, man, music is magic.
不过，音乐这东西，老兄，音乐是有魔力的。
Music is magic.
音乐是有魔力的。
I figured out how to play guitar with my daughter, and I figured out where to capo the guitar to be in the same key as her saxophone, which I didn't know for a while.
我弄清楚了如何和女儿一起弹吉他，我还弄清楚了吉他变调夹该夹在哪里，才能和她的萨克斯保持相同的调子，这一点我有一阵子都不知道。
And you put the capo on the third foot of the guitar, you were very much in C with that saxophone.
你把变调夹夹在吉他的第三品上，配上那个萨克斯，C调的感觉太明显了。
Oh, that's cool.
哦，太酷了。
And it's very cool with that she has an alto sax, and we are doing family bands, like two or three nights a week where we're all jamming, and it's like, I become Marshall.
她用中音萨克斯感觉真的很酷，我们现在搞家庭乐队，一周两三晚大家一起即兴合奏，感觉我就成了马歇尔。
I'm basically becoming Marshall Erickson, the family band thing, and it's fantastic.
我简直成了马歇尔·埃里克森，这种家庭乐队的感觉，太棒了。
That's so cool.
太酷了。
Well, this episode fittingly ends with a great song.
好了，这一集非常应景地以一首很棒的歌收尾。
We'll get to that.
我们待会儿会聊到。
It does.
确实如此。
But this episode was written by whom?
但这一集是谁写的呢？
Was this a Bays and Thomas episode?
这是贝斯和托马斯的剧集吗？
This is an episode written by Matt Coon.
这一集是马特·库恩写的。
This was his second episode.
这是他的第二集。
He wrote for the show.
他为这部剧写过东西。
He wrote columns in season two.
他在第二季写过专栏。
This was the first one that I kind of got to be paired as like the, this was my episode with him.
这是我第一次被安排成和他是这种搭档关系的剧集，这是我和他合作的第一集。
Carter and I would divide and conquer on episodes.
卡特和我会在剧集上分工合作。
And it was just so great to see someone who was our writer assistant or perhaps script coordinator at that time.
看到一个曾经担任我们编剧助理或是当时剧本统筹的人。
I forget what his title is.
我忘了他的具体头衔是什么了。
Just making this big leap and writing this great all-timer episode, it was such a delight.
能够实现这样巨大的跨越，写出这么棒的经典一集，真的让人非常欣喜。
I loved when we got to give those opportunities to the many wonderful people who worked on the show with us.
我很喜欢我们能把这些机会给那些和我们一起工作过许多优秀的伙伴。
Was he already at that point doing Barney's blog and doing the Barney books?
那时候他已经在负责巴尼的博客和巴尼的书了吗？
Yes, he mad.
是的，他写了。
Because he really wrote almost all of those, right?
因为那些基本上全是他写的，对吧？
He did.
没错。
He was the main voice of Barney off network.
他可以说是剧集之外巴尼的核心声音。
He headed up writing the Barney Bro code books that were sort of a spinoff from writing these great Barney's blog entries every week on CBS.com.
他牵头写了巴尼的《兄弟准则》系列书籍，这算是每周在CBS.com上撰写那些精彩的巴尼博客衍生出来的。
was a Barney's blog sort of on theme with the with the episode.
巴尼的博客内容某种程度上也和这一集的主题相呼应。
And he was just he showed so much just hustle.
他展现出了十足的拼劲。
He just like did all of those things that we needed done often for no money.
他把我们需要的那些事情都办妥了，而且通常没有什么报酬。
Sometimes it was like a little money in it.
有时可能会有一点小小的报酬。
But he was he really just did that thing.
但他真的就是做了那样的事。
We've talked about many times, Josh, of just like he just loved doing the work and he wanted to do a great job at every single thing and raised his hand to do extracurricular stuff.
乔希，我们讨论过很多次，他就是那种纯粹热爱这份工作，想把每一件小事都做到极致，并且主动举手要求做一些分外工作的人。
And he became a writer.
然后他成了一名编剧。
It's so cool when you're on a long running show, when you see people rise from like, you know, stapling together the scripts into like being a co-executive producer, being on set, pitching jokes, like, and also, you know, just a shout out to the WGA and they're really fighting against these trimmed writing staffs, not allowing the writers to be on set.
在一部长寿剧中，看到人们从诸如装订剧本之类的基础工作，一路晋升为联合执行制片人、出现在片场、抛出各种笑话梗，这真的太酷了；另外，也要向美国编剧工会（WGA）致敬，他们正在极力抗议这种精简编剧团队、不让编剧去片场的做法。
We've talked about this, but like, I've seen up close, like, how you apprentice and great verb apprentice.
我们讨论过这个，我近距离观察过，你如何当学徒，——“学徒”这个动词用得太妙了。
Yeah, He was an apprentice, like, but almost like in the old tiny sense of like, you'd apprentice with a cobbler, you'd apprentice with someone to learn a trade.
对，他就像个学徒，但几乎有点像老派那种意义上的，跟鞋匠当学徒，跟某人学手艺。
Get your 10,000 hours.
积累你的一万小时定律。
Yeah.
对。
Get it in.
把它练出来。
Talk about the Beatles.
说到披头士。
Like, get in there.
就像那种感觉。
Play a bunch of covers in Hamburg.
在汉堡弹奏一堆翻唱歌曲。
Yeah.
对。
That's the Germany.
就在德国那边。
And he, so he did, he was on all nine seasons of how much mother started and as a registrant and then worked his way all the way up to CoEP.
所以他做到了，他经历了《老爸老妈浪漫史》全部九季，从助理做起，然后一路晋升到联合执行制片人。
This is his first episode and what a great entryway.
这是他的第一集，真是个梦幻般的开端。
It is such a great, I really, really love this episode.
这真是一集太棒了的作品，我真的非常非常喜欢这一集。
Yeah.
对。
A lot.
非常喜欢。
Alec, tell us when this episode aired.
亚历克，告诉我们这一集是什么时候播出的。
This was November 19th, 2007, right around Thanksgiving time.
那是2007年11月19日，差不多是感恩节的时候。
All right.
好吧。
And Craig, I would say this is both an episode of this was your first episode of How I Met Your Mother.
而且克雷格，我想说这既是一集——这是你看的第一集《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
You get it pretty quickly.
你很快就看懂了。
But also, if you've been with the show, it rewards your fidelity.
但同时，如果你一直追这部剧，它会回报你的忠实。
It rewards longtime viewers, most, especially with the slap that, which is one of the great runners in the whole show.
它回报了老观众，尤其是通过那个耳光梗，那是整部剧中最棒的贯穿梗之一。
Koon absolutely crushed it with the script.
库恩的剧本写得绝对棒极了。
It was fantastic.
太棒了。
Yeah, this was one.
对，就是这一集。
This was maybe my favorite one of season three and one of my all time favorites.
这可能是我在第三季中最喜欢的一集，也是我所有剧集中最喜欢的一集。
And it, I think the reason it works, obviously, it starts with this really funny, ridiculous Alec and Joel, whoever came up with a joke.
而且，我认为它成功的原因，很明显，是从这个非常搞笑、荒谬的亚历克和乔尔开始的，不管是谁想出了这个笑话。
I thought, I sort of thought of the emotional core of this episode because of the saluting thing.
我当时想，由于那个敬礼的事情，我想到了这一集的情感核心。
And I'll explain that idea that happens at the end where that idea of friendship is reflexive, that idea occurred to me because of the saluting thing.
我会解释在结尾出现的那个想法，即友谊是条件反射式的，那个想法是因为敬礼的事情才出现在我脑海里的。
Because Josh, just like you said, if you go all in on this joke, it becomes reflexive to you.
因为乔什，就像你说的，如果你全力以赴地开这个玩笑，它就会变成你的条件反射。
You will do it while you're giving birth for crying out loud.
天哪，你甚至在生孩子的时候都会这么做。
And I thought of that idea just occurred to me and this seemed like the perfect example of it.
我想出那个点子只是灵光一现，这似乎是它的完美例证。
We wanted you to know episode where 10 Robin really are having a hard time being friends.
我们想让你们知道这一集里，泰德和罗宾真的很难维持朋友关系。
And I love how we planted the seeds of that.
我喜欢我们是怎么为此埋下伏笔的。
In a few of the earlier episodes of season three, it's weird, they broke up.
在第三季的前几集里，这很奇怪，他们分手了。
They're trying to pretend they're still great friends, but are they?
他们试图假装自己还是好朋友，但真的是吗？
Robin is now bringing a new guy to friend Thanksgiving that they're having.
罗宾现在正带着一个新男友去参加他们聚会的感恩节。
It is weird, it's weird to Ted, they have been distant.
这很奇怪，对泰德来说很奇怪，他们一直保持着距离。
And we wanted to show an episode where they seriously consider not being friends anymore, and then something brings them back, something reflexive, something comes at them that just is undeniable and evocative of their deeper connection that they're supposed to still be in each other's lives.
我们想拍一集，讲他们认真考虑不再做朋友，然后有什么东西把他们拉了回来，某种条件反射般的东西，某种扑面而来、无可否认且唤起他们更深层联系的东西，提醒他们本该继续出现在彼此的生命中。
And somehow that was the big core of this episode that happened kind of right away.
不知何故，这就是这一集的核心，几乎是一开始就想好了。
That was the big idea of this episode right away.
这就是这一集一开始的宏大构想。
Craig, I wrote down friendship as an involuntary reflex, which is what the narrator tells us.
克雷格，我记下了“友谊是一种不由自主的条件反射”，旁白就是这么对我们说的。
Right, right, right, friendship.
对，对，对，友谊。
Yeah, that's what we said.
对，这就是我们说的。
Involuntary reflex.
不由自主的条件反射。
And I thought, you know, it startled me because it's such a smart line.
我想，你知道的，这吓了我一跳，因为这是一句太聪明的台词了。
It's such an insightful line.
这是一句多么深刻的台词啊。
Yeah.
是啊。
But it's also, again, it's in a sitcom on CBS on Monday night.
但它同时，再说一次，它出现在周一晚上哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）的情景喜剧里。
That could be in a Joyce Carol Oates short story.
这可以出现在乔伊斯·卡罗尔·奥茨的短篇小说里。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Like, yes.
就像，是的。
And it's better than I just said it.
而且比我刚才说的还要好。
It's how paraphrased it works.
这就是我意译的效果。
But the thought is really powerful.
但这个想法真的很震撼。
And it's a very mature thought.
而且这是一个非常成熟的想法。
I know the mature character is saying it, but you created a context or a structure where wisdom could seep through.
我知道是成熟的角色在说这句话，但你创造了一个语境或结构，让智慧能够渗透进来。
You know, that's what I think people like about the show.
你知道，这就是我认为人们喜欢这部剧的原因。
They get to see people having too many sandwiches or waking up next to someone they don't know all the folly of being in your late 20s and mid 20s.
他们看到人们吃三明治吃得太多，或者醒来时发现身边躺着一个不认识的人——所有处于二十代末和二十代中期时的愚蠢行径。
But you also have this wisdom and reflection and it's contextualized as like, these were important parts of my life.
但你同时也拥有这种智慧和反思，它的语境就像是：这些是我生命中重要的部分。
This is what I learned.
这就是我所学到的。
I'll say two things, both courtesy of my wife, when the cold open was done, I think when the credits sequence start, she just turned to me, she said, I love this show.
我要说两件事，都承蒙我妻子所赐，当冷开场结束时，我想是片头字幕开始时，她转过头对我说，我爱这部剧。
I just thought it was so, it's like, and she also said, we were talking about how easy they go down, and how you can see when, it used to startle me when people say, I've watched the show 15 times, and I'm like, wait, what do you mean?
我当时觉得太……就像，她还说，我们之前在讨论它们是多么容易看进去，以及你能看出什么时候——过去当人们说“我已经把这剧看了15遍了”时，我会大吃一惊，我想，等等，你什么意思？
How do you have the time?
你怎么会有那么多时间？
But the truth is, you can binge this show pretty quick.
但事实是，你可以非常快地一口气刷完这部剧。
Like my niece is in nephews, like watch this show pretty quick.
就像我的侄子和外甥们，他们看这部剧看得非常快。
Like, you can watch it and if you love it, you can re-watch it, it really goes down smooth.
就比如说，你可以看它，如果你喜欢，你可以反复看，它真的很顺畅。
But also, Jordana was, she said, I'm so glad they're dealing with Ted and Robin still hanging out all the time together.
不过还有，乔达娜说，我很高兴他们还在处理泰德和罗宾一直经常一起混在一起的事。
Like, she felt like it was kind of in certain episodes, this thing wasn't highlighted.
就是，她觉得在某些剧集中，这件事没有被强调。
It just looked like they went from being in a relationship to them being friends, which is obviously tricky, unless you're kind of divorced your emotional life, which neither of them are.
看起来他们只是从恋爱关系变成了朋友，这显然很棘手，除非你有点像把你的情感生活离婚了，而他们两个都没有。
So she was really grateful that you guys were squarely journeying into the storm of this.
所以她真的很感激你们直面并陷入了这场风暴中。
Yeah, me too.
是的，我也是。
I'm really glad we brought that back up.
我真的很高兴我们重新提起了这件事。
We kind of touched upon it the first couple episodes of season three, end of episode two especially.
我们在第三季的前几集稍微触及过这一点，尤其是第二集结尾。
And then it was kind of like, now they're okay and that's not really how life works, right?
然后感觉就像是，现在他们没事了，但生活其实不是这样的，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
You can say now we're okay and move on And it cannot be true.
你可以说现在我们没事了然后继续生活，但这可能不是真的。
It can turn out not to be true.
结果可能会证明这不是真的。
And Thanksgiving felt like a good way to say like, wait, we're all gonna have this Thanksgiving together and Robin's bringing this new guy who is, and we got to say the great.
而感恩节感觉像是一个好方法，就好像在说，等等，我们都要一起过这个感恩节，而且罗宾要带这个新家伙来，他是，我们得说太棒了。
This episode does so many things that are the best things about him, the fallibility of memory, the how I remember this guy.
这一集做了很多能体现他最好特质的事情，记忆的不可靠性，我如何记住这个家伙。
It's kind of like with blah, blah.
有点像布拉，布拉那一集。
I remember this guy was for a handsome 41-year-old athletic guy played by Evan, one of our stand-ins from the show.
我记得这家伙是一个帅气的41岁运动型男，由埃文饰演，他是我们剧组的替身演员之一。
Shout out to Evan.
向埃文致敬。
as shout out to Evan, but I remember him like this and that it's Orson Bean, who are huge fans.
向埃文致敬，但我记忆中的他就是这样，而且那是奥森·比恩，我们都是他的超级粉丝。
He was like a TV fixture.
他就像是电视界的常青树。
He was on like, he is a hilarious guy.
他就像是，他是个超级搞笑的人。
He was on all these like game shows and talk shows.
他上过所有这些游戏节目和脱口秀。
He was like one of those kind of guys in the 60s.
他就像60年代那种类型的家伙。
And then he had that amazing turn in being John Malkovich as John Kuzak's like really crazy and seemingly ancient boss in being John Malkovich.
然后他在《成为马尔科维奇》里有了惊人的转变，饰演约翰·库萨克在《成为马尔科维奇》里那个超级疯狂且看似老态龙钟的老板。
He's so funny and peculiar and unique that we've targeted him, it has to be him.
他是如此有趣、奇特又独特，我们锁定了目标，非他莫属。
He's so funny in this episode.
他在这一集里太搞笑了。
I will say, I do need to apologize for the ages I'm on the show now that we're in.
我要说，对于剧中我们现在所处的年龄，我确实需要道个歉。
We've got to talk about this.
我们得谈谈这个。
Because I am not comfortable with it.
因为我对这个感到不太舒服。
Well, but I will say just you have certain memories.
不过，我要说的是，你确实会有某些记忆。
You know, we talk a lot about, we tell people you'd get big laughs of the table read, maybe big laughs of the network studio run through, big laugh the first time you rehearse it for the crew, and then it's diminishing returns mostly.
你知道，我们经常谈论，我们告诉人们，你在围读剧本时会获得巨大的笑声，在电视网工作室彩排时也许有大笑，第一次为剧组彩排时有大笑，然后基本上就是边际效应递减了。
By the last take, no one's ever thinking about lunch.
到了最后一次拍摄，根本没人会去想午饭的事。
People are, you know, they're phone, yeah.
大家都在，你知道的，看手机，对。
Yeah.
对。
But Orson Bean, my memory is laughter on every take.
但对于奥森·比恩，我的记忆是每一次拍摄都有笑声。
Every take.
每一次。
Every take, he just crushed.
每一次拍摄，他都表现得惊艳。
So funny.
太搞笑了。
He was so funny and he threw it all away in the perfect way.
他太搞笑了，而且他以一种最完美的方式把包袱全抖出去了。
There was a lot of stuff.
有很多东西。
There's a bad way to do that role.
演那个角色有一种糟糕的方式。
Like there's a, he let himself be the joke and he played it like pretty straight.
就好像有一种，他让自己成了笑柄，而且他演得很正经。
Which is like so much funnier.
这反而搞笑多了。
so much fun, like tried to amp it up and be.
太好玩了，就像试图夸大其词然后变成。
Yeah, he just was.
对，他就是那样。
He's so funny, R.I.P, who we've lost him since then, he's great.
他太搞笑了，R.I.P，我们后来失去他了，他太棒了。
Oh, I didn't know that.
哦，我不知道这件事。
He was Phil Lord's neighbor at one point in Venice and Phil, I'm gonna be like, oh yeah, I see Orson B and all the time down at the beach in Venice, which I was like, that is a cool neighbor to have.
他曾经是菲尔·洛德在威尼斯的邻居，菲尔会说，哦对，我经常在威尼斯的沙滩上看到奥森·比恩，我当时想，那真是个酷炫的邻居。
Orson B in Venice.
奥森·比恩在威尼斯。
Yeah.
对。
He's just, he was a character that guy and he was very, very funny, but the 41 year old joke is not aging well for me.
他就是，那家伙很有个性，而且非常非常搞笑，但41岁那个笑话现在对我的年龄来说不太合时宜了。
In some ways though, you guys were on to yourself because even though when there's always a flash forward and Marshall's 42, you make him like 6,000.
不过从某种程度上说，你们也是在自嘲，因为哪怕总是有闪回，马歇尔42岁时，你们把他化得像6000岁一样。
He's a hundred and sixty-two years old.
他有一百六十二岁。
But you guys in some ways were calling attention to, oh, this happened to be yesterday in the airport in Miami.
但从某种程度上说，你们也是在呼应，哦，这事儿是昨天在迈阿密机场发生的。
I'm getting a cup of coffee and these two, I think they were in college, these girls behind me.
我正在买杯咖啡，然后这两个，我想她们是大学生，我身后的这两个女孩。
They- I'm nervous.
她们——我好紧张。
I don't even know what's gonna happen when I'm nervous.
我甚至不知道我紧张的时候会发生什么。
It says, one of them says, Um, my, uh, my brother is like always dating these older girls and like, he's 23 and he was dating this 28 year old.
她说，其中一个说，嗯，我，呃，我哥哥总是跟这些大龄女孩约会，比如他23岁，然后他在跟一个28岁的约会。
And she said, well, I want to get, we should get married because I want to have a baby and it's like, I'm only 23.
她说，嗯，我想结婚，我们应该结婚，因为我想生个孩子，然后就像是，我才23岁。
And so he broke up with her.
所以他就和她分手了。
And my older sister is 26 and she's dating a 30 year old because she likes older guys.
而我姐姐26岁，她在和一个30岁的人约会，因为她喜欢年纪大一点的男生。
And then she literally said, can you imagine 30?
然后她字面意义上地说，你能想象30岁吗？
Oh no.
哦不。
Oh my God.
我的天哪。
And I'm like standing, I'm in front of them at, you know, 51.
而我当时站在，我站在她们前面，你知道的，51岁。
Oh, looking like a decent, like I'm holding it together, but I was also like, I felt like the Crip Keepers dad, you know?
哦，看起来像个正经人，就像我心态还稳得住，但我也同时觉得，我觉得自己像个《魔界奇谭》守墓人的爸爸，你知道吗？
Not the Crip Keepers dad.
不是守墓人的爸爸。
That's a great turn of phrase.
这真是一个绝妙的说法。
That was a matter of time.
那是迟早的事。
But it also shows you like when you're 22.
但这同时也向你表明，当你22岁的时候。
Yeah.
对。
30 is ancient.
30岁就是远古时期了。
41.
41岁。41岁。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Well, look at us fucking little shitting.
好吧，看看我们这群混蛋小鬼。
Are you picking out your grave plot?
你们在挑墓地吗？
We're like 32 writing that 41 looked like Orson Bean.
我们大概32岁写下41岁看起来像奥森·比恩的剧本。
And Orson Bean looked great for whatever age he was, but we were a little dicks of that age.
而且奥森·比恩不管在什么年纪看起来都很棒，但我们那个年纪就是一群小混蛋。
But you also acknowledge by the storyline itself, you acknowledge that two or 28 year old 41 can look.
但你们通过剧情本身也承认了，28岁或41岁看起来可以是什么样。
Right, and Robin also says why are you, and also Ted is jealous and upset, Ted is jealous, Ted is choosing to view this guy as ancient to cushion.
对，罗宾也说你为什么，而且泰德也很嫉妒很不爽，泰德在嫉妒，泰德选择把这家伙看作老古董来给自己当缓冲垫。
Yeah, also Jordana said to me, she goes, that's our age difference, which is 13 years.
对，乔达娜也对我说，她说，那正是我们的年龄差，也就是13岁。
Oh my God.
我的天哪。
Yeah, so we had a lot of fun with that one.
是的，所以我们在那一集里玩得很开心。
But he was fantastic and the whole joke is great.
但他太棒了，整个笑话也很棒。
I mean, part of this, the reason I think this episode, I really like looking at when the show is firing on all cylinders, why it's working so well.
我的意思是，部分原因，我认为这一集，我真的很喜欢看当这部剧火力全开时，为什么它能运作得这么好。
Yeah.
对。
Right.
对吧。
I think one Thanksgiving is a perfect setting for this because Thanksgiving is when the nerve endings are raw and like it's a time of togetherness, but it's also often the time of conflict is the time where things get said that maybe might not otherwise get said or it's a very provocative time.
我认为一个感恩节是完美的背景，因为感恩节是神经末梢最脆弱的时候，它是一个团聚的时刻，但往往也是冲突的时刻，是那些平时可能不会说出口的话被说出来的时刻，或者这是一个非常具有挑衅性的时刻。
Yes, so I love the setting.
是的，所以我喜欢这个背景。
I love, I think that how I make your mother's best when it's bar and apartments.
我喜欢，我认为《老爸老妈浪漫史》最好看的时候就是在酒吧和公寓里。
Me too.
我也是。
You know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Yes.
是的。
It's like when it's on its home turf, it somehow is like.
就好像当它回到主场时，不知为什么它就像是。
Because everything in the universe can be contained in those, if you tell the story right, you don't need anything more.
因为宇宙中的一切都可以包含在那些场景中，如果你故事讲得对，你不需要任何别的东西。
You can find infinity in those couple of sets and you can find, you don't need to do all of these bells and whistles in other locations.
你可以在那几个布景里找到无限，你可以找到，你不需要在其他地方搞那些花里胡哨的东西。
Yeah, it actually preserves the core energy somehow.
是的，它不知何故实际上保留了核心能量。
But you have the A story between Ted and Robin is like incredibly emotional.
但你们在泰德和罗宾之间安排的A线故事又极其具有情感张力。
It's incredibly on brand in terms of Ted trying to figure out his romantic life.
就泰德试图搞清楚他的浪漫生活而言，这极其符合他的人设。
And then the B story, I would say, the slap is just like one of the most delightfully, like it's the comedic motor of the slap and the five slaps and when is the next slap gonna come.
然后是B线剧情，我觉得，巴掌这场戏简直太美妙了，巴掌以及五个耳光就是喜剧的动力，还有下一个巴掌什么时候来。
and Marshall's absolute glee in taunting Barney and Neil, and Neil's like terror.
马歇尔在嘲弄巴尼和尼尔时那种绝对的幸灾乐祸，以及尼尔的恐惧。
And he did something like where he pictured it in his eye like twitch.
他还做了那种好像把画面印在眼里的动作，比如眼皮抽搐。
It was amazing.
太绝了。
It looked like a cartoon.
看起来就像个动画片。
Do you know what I'm talking about?
你知道我在说什么吗？
I know exactly what you mean.
我完全明白你的意思。
Yeah, this quivering lip and eye and cheek, it was, it was, and his bravado that you ruined it, but it turns out he didn't ruin it.
对，这种嘴唇、眼睛和面颊的颤抖，真的是，而且那种“你把它给毁了”的虚张声势，但结果证明他根本没毁掉。
It's even worse knowing that it's going to happen.
明知道接下来要发生什么，那种感觉就更折磨了。
Like everyone had an arc.
就像每个人都有一个故事弧光。
Even in those stupid little things, there was like an ABC, there was like points in the story, right?
即使在那些蠢萌的小事情里，也有类似于A、B、C的结构，故事里有各种节点，对吧？
There's like an emotional through line for everybody.
每个人都有情感上的隐秘主线。
Like Lily is really mama bear in this episode.
比如莉莉在这个剧集里真的很有老妈子的风范。
She's both the slap at commissioner, which is like a mama bear role.
她既是巴掌仲裁委员会委员，这本身就像个老妈子的角色。
And also like trying to create this nice thing, and they're first, they're first friends together, which is a big fucking deal, right?
同时还努力促成这件美好的事，而且这是他们第一次，他们第一次作为朋友聚在一起，这可是件了不起的大事，对吧？
And she wants it to go out.
并且她希望事情能顺利进行。
That's the other stakes of the episode.
这就是这一集的另一个赌注。
She's trying to create a tradition.
她正试图建立一个传统。
Right.
没错。
It's very sad when Marshall says, we're going to do this every year, right?
当马歇尔说，我们每年都要这样做，不觉得很悲伤吗？
After we've just heard Ted and Ramana green, not to be friends anymore.
就在我们刚听到泰德和罗宾达成一致、不再做朋友之后。
It's really sad.
真的让人很难过。
It just, there's so many emotional moments in this.
里面真的有太多动人的时刻了。
It's also very chosen.
而且这也非常契合。
This episode's very chosen family episode.
这一集非常强调“选择的家庭”这个概念。
Like, why aren't they with their families?
比如，为什么他们不和家人在一起？
Yeah, it's chosen family.
对，这就是由选择构成的家庭。
And also, like, think about how the religious dogma of this friend group, the incredibly intricate or innate religious dogma, the rules of the slap bet, the major general kernel thing, the incredibly like Byzantine or innate sort of inner logic, this other language that this friend group has developed, the whole episode is about that.
还有，你想想这个朋友群体的宗教教条，那种极其错综复杂或根深蒂固的宗教教条、巴掌赌局的规则、那个重大将军的核心梗，那种极其拜占庭风格或内在的逻辑，这种朋友群体开发出的另一种语言，整集其实都是围绕这个展开的。
It's about their language.
这关乎他们的语言。
It's their vernacular.
那是他们的方言。
They're getting about like creating mythology, their own mythology.
他们正致力于创造神话，他们自己的神话。
Yes.
没错。
It's the mythology of this group.
这就是这个群体创造的神话。
It's the native tongue of this group.
这是这个群体的母语。
And nobody else speaks quite like them.
没有其他人能像他们那样说话。
No one else has these inside jokes.
也没有其他人有这些内部笑话。
And here we're at risk of losing some part of this group or what's gonna happen to this whole group and that's the stakes of the episode.
而此时我们面临着失去这个群体一部分的风险，或者说整个群体会变成什么样，这就是这一集的赌注所在。
what's gonna happen are these jokes are all gonna scatter to the wind like dandelion spores.
会发生什么呢？这些笑话会像蒲公英的孢子一样四处飘散吗？
That's another reason I think this episode works.
这也是我认为这一集成功的原因之一。
It's like, I don't know if it's chicken or egg, like things are extra funny when, no, I would say that's probably a comedic truth.
这就好像，我不知道是先有鸡还是先有蛋，当——不对，我觉得这大概是一个喜剧真理。
Things are funnier when the stakes are higher.
当赌注更高时，事情会更好笑。
And when there's real sadness along the way.
当过程中伴随着真实的悲伤时。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对，对。
I believe that wholeheartedly.
我对此深信不疑。
Like the absurdity of the slap, which is so simple.
就像巴掌的荒谬感一样，它是如此简单。
It's like Buster Heaton simple.
就像巴斯特·基顿式的简单。
like a shout out to Alakula, I suppose you're getting out today.
就像是对阿拉库拉的致敬，我想你今天也要出场了。
You take the smallest little premise and you just explore it from every nook and cranny.
你拿出一个微小的假设，然后从角角落落去挖掘它。
But underneath it, parallel alongside it is one of the elements of the gang, of this five person perfectly structured into something is possibly going to be extracted.
但在它之下，与它平行伴随着的是这帮人的其中一个元素，这个由五个人完美构成的结构可能会被剥离。
Like it's really heartbreaking.
这真的让人心碎。
Yeah.
对。
And Robin and Ted are the only ones that know it.
而且只有罗宾和泰德知道这一点。
And Marshall's giving a toast saying we're all gonna do this for years to come.
马歇尔还在敬酒说我们以后每年都要这样。
And it's really sad.
这真的很悲伤。
And it's really deeply sad and then deeply moving that they, without ever talking about it explicitly, we see them decide to be friends via this amazing inside joke that Joel invented in their, and Alec's a great group.
真的非常悲伤，然后又非常感人，他们从来没有明确谈论过，我们看着他们通过乔尔在他们的——还有亚历克是个伟大的团队里发明的这个惊人的内部笑话，决定继续做朋友。
Hi, I'm just wanted to see if Alec is still paying.
嗨，我只是想看看亚历克是不是还在付钱。
He's gonna cut that out, he's gonna cut that out.
他会把这段剪掉的，他会剪掉的。
I also just wanna just add, by the way that you've, you define this familial world that you've created with their codes of their logic of everything.
我还想顺便补充一点，你定义了你所创造的这个充满条理、逻辑以及一切的家族世界。
And then what's wild, of course, is you've given that to the world who writes to us by the thousands that they use the same, they use those codes.
然后最疯狂的是，当然，你把这个世界交给了成千上万给我们写信的观众，他们也在使用同样的暗号。
They use those languages in their friends circles.
他们在自己的朋友圈子里也使用那些语言。
Also, you've sort of given that out.
此外，你相当于把这些分享了出去。
It's extraordinary.
这太非同寻常了。
It's global, it's gone global.
这是全球性的，已经走向全球了。
If you speak that language on, say, a dating site, and someone else speaks that language, they will flag you.
如果你在比如交友网站上说那种语言，而另一个人也懂那种语言，他们就会注意到你。
You know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
We've heard it.
我们听说过。
People get married because they like the Joel's joke.
有人因为喜欢乔尔的笑话而结为夫妻。
Yeah, they like Joel's joke.
对，他们喜欢乔尔的笑话。
Wait, it keeps happening.
等等，这种事一直在发生。
Or they just, there's a kind of thing like, you're a little bit pre-approved.
或者他们只是觉得，有一种类似“你已经有点被预先通过审核”的感觉。
Like if you love how I met your mother so much and you meet someone you're attracted to who loves how I met your mother so much, that is shorthand for a very particular kind of thing.
就像如果你非常喜欢《老爸老妈浪漫史》，然后你遇到了一个你觉得有吸引力、也同样非常喜欢《老爸老妈浪漫史》的人，那这就是某种特定事物的简写。
It's friendship is an involuntary reflex.
友谊是一种条件反射。
Like it is that, it's that thing.
就像那样，就是那种感觉。
And I like that we see Ted and Robin try to throw their friendship away and it doesn't take.
我喜欢我们看到泰德和罗宾试图抛弃他们的友谊，结果却行不通。
They take this friendship and they say we're throwing it, we're going to drown this friendship in the East River and it doesn't want to go.
他们抓起这段友谊并宣称：我们要把它扔掉，我们要把这段友谊淹死在东河里，但它就是不肯走。
It comes back around.
它又转回来了。
It's like a horror movie but a very happy horror movie that the friendship is like, nope, I'm coming back.
这就像一部恐怖片，但却是一部非常欢乐的恐怖片，友谊仿佛在说：不，我要回来了。
You tried to kill me but there's something here that is unkillable and we're going to stay friends because of this stupid joke because we speak the same language and I love that moment.
你试图杀了我，但这里有些东西是杀不死的，我们将因为这个愚蠢的笑话继续做朋友，因为我们说的是同一种语言，我太喜欢那个时刻了。
You and Colby are fantastic in this episode and fantastic in that moment.
你和科比在这集里表现得太棒了，在那个时刻也表现得太棒了。
I watched it with my wife Rebecca and I could tell she got very moved by that moment.
我和我妻子丽贝卡一起看的，我能看出她被那个时刻深深打动了。
It just clicked for her watching.
看着它的时候，那种共鸣自然而然就发生了。
I could just feel it.
我能感觉得到。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, it's also really nice that it starts off as this quirky, silly signifier of how and mesh they are in it and noise their friends until their friends start doing it because it's such a sticky joke, and then it turns out to be the very sweet touching thing that ends the episode and lets us know it's going to be okay.
嗯，而且最棒的是，它一开始只是一个古怪、傻气的标志，表明他们陷得有多深，并以此烦扰他们的朋友，直到他们的朋友也开始模仿，因为这个笑话太深入人心了，接着它变成了这一集结尾那个非常甜蜜动人的东西，让我们知道一切都会好起来的。
And it infects the whole group like an outbreak movie, the group is finally starting to do it involuntarily themselves.
它像《极度恐慌》里的病毒一样感染了整个群体，大家最终开始不由自主地自己模仿起来。
We don't say who came up with it, Ted or Robin.
我们没说究竟是谁想出来的，是泰德还是罗宾。
See Alec, it doesn't matter, you and Joel don't need to argue, it's just sort of born out of nowhere, Ted and Robin just start doing and it's a connection, does it really matter who invented it really?
看吧亚历克，这根本不重要，你和乔尔不需要争论，它只是凭空诞生，泰德和罗宾就是开始用了，这是一种连接，谁发明的真的有那么重要吗？
It doesn't matter that I invented it.
我发明的这并不重要。
Go on.
继续。
Good.
好。
And this old man.
还有这个老头。
He must'd meet me.
他一定得见我。
Fell in love with you.
爱上了你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在是广告时间。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，Hyper-Fixed播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会接受听众的烦恼并试着帮他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：我三十岁了，却很害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么当我挂倒车档时，汽车音响的音量无法调节？
in reverse.
在倒车时。
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也会解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你遇到了问题，我们不仅会解决它，还会揭示导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或访问 HyperFixedPod.com 收听。
And if commercials, back to Shell.
广告过后，欢迎回到《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
Craig, not to bring up old wounds or get a viewer, mail, whatever, but I want to talk about the finale for one second without any spoilers, which is the script for the finale was too fat for the amount of time we had.
克雷格，我不是想挑起旧伤或者提起观众来信什么的，但我只想花一秒钟聊聊大结局，没有任何剧透，那就是大结局的剧本对于我们拥有的时长来说太长了。
Even though it was a two-part episode, ads were very expensive.
尽管这是一个上下集的剧集，但广告非常昂贵。
A lot of people were gonna be tuning in.
会有很多人收看。
You guys had to trim the episode, right?
你们不得不删减这一集，对吧？
We did, yeah.
是的，确实如此。
One of my top 10 life regrets is not fighting for like an extra half hour of that, but we'll get there.
我人生中最大的十个遗憾之一，就是没有为那一集争取多出大约半小时的时长，不过我们等下会聊到这个。
You guys lost a scene with me and Kobe in the family.
你们删掉了一场我和科比还有家人的戏。
We did.
是的。
That I think is on DVD extras if you...
我想那段被收录在 DVD 的花絮里，如果你……
Oh, it is.
哦，确实是的。
People can go find it.
大家可以去找来看看。
Even on YouTube, I think, right?
甚至在 YouTube 上也能找到，对吧？
Yeah, you can YouTube it.
对，你可以在 YouTube 上搜到。
It's like Ted, Robin, Finale, Cutscene.
大概是“泰德，罗宾，大结局，被删片段”。
It's a great scene, I in retrospect, I really wish it was in there.
这是一场很棒的戏，回想起来，我真的很希望它能保留在正片里。
And it ends with a major joke, right?
而且它以一个重磅笑话结尾，对吧？
Like isn't it?
是不是这样？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
I forget what the exacts.
我忘了具体细节了。
Oh man, it would have we should, yeah.
天哪，本来应该……我们当时应该……
But I remember the finale, which obviously is tear-filled and beautiful, or had so many moments that were so moving, especially like around the table, but I remember when I read it, I think that was the moment that got me because it was such a signifier of their history and their fondness for each other, and their shorthand and...
但我记得大结局，显然那是充满泪水且美丽动人的，或者说有太多让人动容的时刻，特别是围坐在桌子周围的那一段，但我记得当我读到剧本时，那似乎是真正触动我的瞬间，因为那是他们过往经历、彼此喜爱以及他们之间默契的强烈象征，而且……
Yeah, it's their connection.
对，那是他们之间的羁绊。
I think he leaves after she says something, and then he just turns out the door and gives her a salute.
我想在她说了句话之后他便离开了，然后他转身走向门口，向她敬了个礼。
Like, you know, even going to watch those, even saying it, you know.
你看，甚至在回顾这些片段，甚至在说出这些时，你懂的。
But it's gonna bother me, that it's not in there.
但这还是会让我觉得烦恼，它没有被剪进正片里。
Anyway, we'll get there.
不管怎样，我们待会儿会聊到。
Hey, I have a question for you, since you're so, since you and Carter were so rom-com literate, When they come to the Thanksgiving, and Ted is talking to the guys in one room, and Robin's talking to Lily in the kitchen, and they're both telling about their night, and with all the flashbacks, it very much reminded me of Bruno Kirby and Carrie Fisher calling- On the phone and the t-shirt screen as it's like the four, yeah, it's great, right?
嘿，我有个问题想问你，既然你和卡特对浪漫喜剧如此了解，当他们来到感恩节聚餐，泰德和几个男生在一个房间聊天，罗宾和莉莉在厨房聊天，他们都在讲述各自的夜晚经历，伴随着各种闪回，这非常让我想起比利·克里斯托和梅格·瑞恩……哦不，是布鲁诺·科比和卡丽·费舍尔在电话里通话以及分屏的场景，就像那四个人的场景，对吧，太棒了，对吧？
Do you think that was conscious or unconscious?
你觉得这是刻意为之还是无意之举？
I think it was conscious.
我觉得是刻意为之。
We love when Harry Metzali so much.
我们太喜欢《当哈利遇到莎莉》了。
We did many a nod, some might call it rip-offs, but it's literally, they slept together.
我们致敬了许多次，有些人可能会说是抄袭，但实际上，他们睡过了。
It's the same beat as Bruno Kirby calling, you know, Billy Crystal called Bruno Kirby.
这和布鲁诺·科比打电话的节奏一模一样，你知道的，比利·克里斯托给布鲁诺·科比打电话。
It's a, yeah, I think that's, you know, that's like the bible that, when Harry Met Sally is like, it's just gonna get referenced.
这是一个……是的，我认为这就好像是那种圣经般的存在，《当哈利遇到莎莉》就是会被不断拿出来致敬。
It's just such an all-timer.
它就是这样一部永恒的经典。
But yeah, I mean, that's the other thing.
但话又说回来，还有一件事。
I love that this episode had the flashbacks, it had the mystery, wait, what crazy thing happened last night?
我喜欢这一集里的闪回，它有悬念，等等，昨晚到底发生了什么疯狂的事？
played with time.
它玩转了时间线。
It had the inside jokes.
它有剧迷才懂的内部笑梗。
It had the incredibly silly sort of B story and the very emotional A story.
它有极其无厘头的B线剧情和非常感人的A线剧情。
It's hard to do that every week.
每周都要做到这一点很难。
It's hard to do that 24 episodes a year and to have all of those things firing.
一年拍24集，还要让所有这些元素都火力全开，这太难了。
But goddamn, this one does.
但天哪，这一集做到了。
This one has it has them all firing and it really is joyful.
这一集把所有元素都发挥得淋漓尽致，真的让人看着很开心。
this one.
这一集就是这样。
Um, I'm trying to remember when, when did the Borat movie come out?
嗯，我一直在想，什么时候，那个《波拉特》电影是什么时候上映的？
Because there's a poor edge with the wrong, the wrong, how many days in a month, but it was funny because like Borat at that point was like oversaturated and a little bit done.
因为有一个关于错把月份天数算错的梗，但很好笑，因为当时《波拉特》已经有点过时且被过度消费了。
Yes, but there's something about it now that is like even funnier than when it was.
是的，但现在看这一段，感觉甚至比当时还要好笑。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Yes, that joke aged well.
是的，这个笑话经受住了时间的考验。
It did age well by age weirdly well.
确实经受住了时间的考验，以一种奇特的方式经受住了。
Yeah.
对。
Because Borat just became like a thing in the culture rather than like a movie event, it's marked by time.
因为《波拉特》后来在文化中变成了一种现象，而不仅仅是一部电影事件，它被时间铭记了。
Yes.
没错。
So it was that was great.
所以这真的很棒。
Speaking of another nod to television, I would say, and maybe because I saw it in college after a lot of sandwiches, but my sophomore year of college, we used to watch The Simpsons a lot as college folks did in those days.
说到对电视剧的另一次致敬，我想说，也许是因为我在大学抽了很多“三明治”之后看的，但我的大学二年级时，我们经常看《辛普森一家》，正如那时的大学生们常做的那样。
All sandwich stuff.
全都是“三明治”梗。
And it's the Side Show Bob Cape Fear episode, which I still think is one of the greatest episodes of television.
那是《恐怖角》里杂耍鲍勃的那一集，我至今仍认为那是电视史上最伟大的剧集之一。
Amazing episode.
极其精彩的一集。
Amazing.
太棒了。
So the way that Side Show Bob taunts Bart and telegraphs, I'm going to kill you.
杂耍鲍勃挑衅巴特并暗示“我要杀了你”的那种方式。
Yeah.
对。
Is just what Marshall does to Barney with a slap.
简直就是马歇尔用耳光对巴尼做的事。
Like, so good in this, he's so good at doing that.
真的，他在这方面太棒了，他太擅长表现这种状态了。
He's doing, like, Sideshow Bob, about the slap rather than murder, but it really reminded me of that episode.
他在模仿杂耍鲍勃，只不过是为了耳光而不是谋杀，但它真的让我想起了那一集。
It is Sideshow Bob.
那就是杂耍鲍勃。
See what I got going on here with the turkeys, their hands, but they're also turkeys.
看看我这边的火鸡，它们有手，但它们也是火鸡。
He played that with such, like, absolute, like, ominous glee.
他把那种绝对的、不祥的幸灾乐祸表现得淋漓尽致。
He leaned into that speed so hard.
他把那种语调拿捏得死死的。
He's great.
他太棒了。
Everyone was good in this.
每个人在这集里都很棒。
Everyone was good.
每个人都表现得很棒。
trying to keep the group from devolving an anarchy and have this one nice Thanksgiving and then giving up and getting drunk and going, I don't care, get up and get out of here, this sucks.
试图阻止这个群体陷入无政府状态，想要过一个美好的感恩节，然后选择放弃、喝醉，然后说，我不在乎，都给我起来滚出去，这太糟糕了。
Like everybody had somewhere to go and then Bob was just kind of writing on his own for a chill plan.
就像每个人都有地方可去，然后鲍勃只是为了一个轻松的计划而顺便加入。
But in some ways, Bob, not just because of the many, many hilarious old-person jokes, which I wanna get into, but it's almost like having Bob there forced, So like, when an outsider is present, it highlights the insider-ness.
但在某些方面，鲍勃的存在，不仅仅是因为那些非常非常搞笑的老年人笑话（我想深入聊聊这个），几乎就像有鲍勃在场一样，强行制造了……就像当一个局外人在场时，会突显出局内人的特质。
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Yes.
是的。
Yeah, I think that is a key to this episode.
对，我认为这是这一集的关键所在。
I don't think the episode works without Bob.
我觉得如果没有鲍勃，这一集就成立不了。
Yeah, you absolutely need Bob.
对，你绝对需要鲍勃。
And also what a pleasant slash innocuous presence he is.
而且他是一个多么讨人喜欢又人畜无害的存在啊。
Like even during the end song, he's just leaning against the wall.
就像在片尾曲期间，他只是靠在墙上。
He's just chilling.
他只是在放松。
Having a great time.
玩得很开心。
Like he actually seems like a good dude.
感觉他实际上是个好人。
Yeah, he does.
对，他确实是。
He seems like a good dude.
他看起来是个好人。
Ted's frying the heat of him.
泰德……
seems very chill.
显得非常轻松。
Yeah.
对。
And that's song.
还有那首歌。
And I will give Carter base.
我要把功劳记在卡特头上。
That is a Carter base original.
那是卡特原创的。
I maybe contributed a couple of little touches here and there, but sometimes like one or the other of us took a song a little more than the other.
我可能在这里那里加了一点小修饰，但有时我们俩中确实有一个人对某首歌的贡献更多一些。
I just want to give credit where it's due.
我只是想该给功劳的时候就给。
You just got slapped is an anthem by Carter is just a frickin banger all time and also if you want to get sports arenas like when another team is losing.
《你刚挨了一巴掌》是卡特创作的一首神曲，绝对是一首历久弥新的劲爆金曲，而且如果你想在体育馆里用它，比如当另一支球队落后的时候。
I really do.
我真的是这么想的。
Do people play it?
真的有人在播吗？
Yeah.
对啊。
If anyone knows where those clips are, I know it has happened.
如果谁知道那些剪辑在哪，我知道这确实发生过。
I think there was a team that did it a lot, like a hockey team maybe.
我想曾有一支球队经常放这首歌，好像是一支冰球队。
That song is transcendently good and the great Carter Bay deserves most of the credit on that one.
那首歌好得超越了一切，伟大的卡特·贝斯应该居功至伟。
If you want Jason Siegel to be very interested.
如果你想让杰森·席格尔非常感兴趣。
See what giving credit is like Alex?
看到了吗，亚历克斯，给别人记功是什么感觉？
See what I just gave credit to Carter.
看我刚才怎么把功劳记在卡特头上了。
I don't need to fight about it.
我没必要为此争吵。
See what that feels like it felt good.
看到那种感觉了吗，感觉挺好的。
And it's just and so that's what we should tell Joel.
而且这正是我们应该告诉乔尔的。
All right, if you want to get Jason Siegel very interested in how I met your mother episode, give him slaps.
好吧，如果你想让杰森·席格尔对《老爸老妈浪漫史》的某一集非常感兴趣，那就给他扇耳光的剧情。
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
And give him a frickin all time at now.
再给他一首绝对的经典神曲。
He was he was all in.
他当时——他完全投入了。
He was locked and loaded.
他整装待发、严阵以待。
He knew this was a good one.
他知道这一集很棒。
He knows this is a good one.
This is just that episode that's good for everybody, including Bob.
这一集对所有人都很棒，包括鲍勃在内。
It's just like everybody plus Bob has like A-game material in this episode and for me I remember really liking this episode as an actor because I got to do what I felt like I was really hired for Which is the more sincere stuff.
就好像每个人加上鲍勃在这一集里都拿出了最高水平，对我来说，我记得作为演员我真的很喜欢这一集，因为我得以做那些我觉得自己真正被雇佣来做的事情，也就是那些更真诚的内容。
That's as the romantic protagonist, but then We're deep enough into the weeds of the show that you guys had a lot of like go-to Ted humor Yeah, and especially Ted Robin dynamic humor, which which we had really found by that point So I felt like both funny and I got to be like a really good actor, you know, it was just like everyone you're right Everyone was in their sweet spot and Ted Ted also got to be a little bit of a dick, right?
那是作为浪漫男主角的戏份，但同时我们对这部剧的挖掘已经够深了，你们有很多泰德式的标志性幽默，是的，尤其是泰德和罗宾之间的动态幽默，我们在那个阶段真的找到了这种感觉，所以我既觉得搞笑，又能展现自己是个真正的好演员，你知道的，就好像每个人——你说得对，每个人都处于最佳状态，而且泰德在这一集里也变得有点混蛋，对吧？
He was a little sharp towards Bob Bob did bother Ted.
他对鲍勃有点刻薄。鲍勃确实惹烦了泰德。
He pretended it didn't but it did and Those scenes with Robin in the kitchen and cooking together were really awkward and painful in a great way.
他假装没有，但其实有，而且那些和罗宾在厨房里一起做饭的戏份真的非常尴尬和痛苦，但又恰到好处。
Yeah Well, that's the other thing you guys did was you never Sanctified anyone like no one was ever everyone had spiky, sharp edges.
对，还有一件事你们做得很好，那就是你们从不把任何人圣化，没有谁是完美的，每个人身上都有尖锐、刻薄的棱角。
And I think that's what makes you trust you guys as storytellers and the characters as people you wanna spend time with because they have the recognizable whiff of reality about them, you know?
我想正是这一点让你信任你们这些创作者，以及这些你想与之共度时光的角色，因为他们身上有一种我们熟悉的真实气息，你知道吗？
Yes, this episode is one of those work.
是的，这一集就是那种神作。
Every now and again, there's an episode that's 22 minutes or like what you said about the finale.
时不时就会有一集只有22分钟的剧集，或者就像你对大结局的评价那样。
I always wish there was more time in every fucking episode we ever did.
我总是希望我们拍的每一集该死的剧集都能有更多时间。
But every once in a while, I go, this did all the things in 21 and a half minutes.
但每隔一段时间，我就会想，这一集在短短二十一分半里把所有事情都做完了。
this kind of did all the things.
这一集基本上把该做的事都做了。
I don't think we left anything on the playing field here.
我觉得我们在这集里没有留下任何遗憾。
This one just somehow fit into like 22 minutes.
这一集不知怎么的就刚好塞进了大约22分钟里。
It's not even quite, I think.
我觉得甚至都还不到。
And it did all the things.
而且它把所有事情都兼顾到了。
And that's really hard to do.
这真的很难做到。
It doesn't happen every time.
并不是每次都能做到的。
And I just, I really appreciate this one.
我真的很喜欢这一集。
Yeah, it must have been fun.
对，当时一定很有趣。
Again, I always like those moments where I can picture the writer's room going, okay, 20 old jokes go.
再说一次，我总是喜欢那些能让我脑补编剧室场景的时刻，大家都在说：“好了，有20个关于老人的笑话，开始吧。”
Right.
没错。
What's a funny way?
怎么说才搞笑呢？
but it's a really twisted, ornate, overly long way to say someone's old.
但那是一种非常扭曲、华丽且极其啰嗦的方式来形容一个人老。
Yeah.
对。
I love Robin is dating Orville Rhett and Bocker.
我喜欢罗宾在跟奥维尔·雷特和邦克约会这个梗。
This is great.
这太棒了。
I loved 41 because I just like this because he's a thousand years old.
我喜欢41岁那个梗，因为我就是喜欢这样，因为他有一千岁了。
I like that's not even a joke.
我喜欢那甚至都不能算是一个笑话。
Just not even joke.
根本算不上笑话。
It's just like the joke is it's just a joke.
就好像笑话本身就是个笑话。
It's just to be him being a baby.
纯粹是为了显得他像个婴儿。
Yes.
没错。
Yeah.
对。
I liked Noah gave him shotgun in the arc shotgun in the arc.
我喜欢诺亚在方舟里给他的那个位置——方舟里的“副驾驶座位”。
Yeah.
对。
I love what there's just a little tight five by 10 there on old jokes.
我喜欢他们关于老人的笑话里那短短五到十秒的快节奏包袱。
He's about to go into some Yomama jokes after that.
他之后差点就要讲起“你妈”的笑话了。
Exactly, exactly.
没错，没错。
But I also really liked, I remember liking Kobe and I being awkward together and the humor, like just, we weren't playing jokes as much as like behavior, you know?
但我真的很喜欢，我记得我喜欢柯比和我在一起时的那种尴尬感以及幽默感，就像是——我们与其说是在抖包袱，不如说是在展现行为举止，你知道吗？
Yeah, and what I like about that is it's the thing that did make the show different from the other shows on CBS and most other sitcoms.
对，我喜欢这一点的原因在于，正是这一点让这部剧区别于CBS的其他节目以及大多数其他情景喜剧。
The show has a memory.
这部剧是有记忆的。
It doesn't reset week to week.
它不会每周都重置。
It doesn't shake up the address sketch.
它不会每次都把人物设定全盘推翻。
The memory is, if two people are very serious together, like Ted and Robin were, and they break up, it takes a long time for it to normalize.
它的记忆在于，如果两个人曾非常认真地交往过，比如泰德和罗宾，然后他们分手了，要花很长时间才能恢复正常。
And sometimes it doesn't.
有时甚至恢复不了。
Sometimes they have to stop being friends.
有时他们不得不停止做朋友。
And the idea that it's not just like, and they're back to normal.
那种“事情发生后，大家马上就恢复正常了”的设定并不存在。
Yes.
是的。
It's like things happen and they matter.
这就好比事情发生了，而且它们很重要。
There were consequences to things happening.
事情的发生是会有后果的。
There is a accumulation of emotional, you know, repercussions that matters and stays and doesn't keep disappearing into nothingness just because it's comedically convenient for it to disappear.
情感上的积淀、你知道的，各种余波是重要且持久的，不会仅仅因为为了喜剧效果方便让它消失，它就凭空消失了。
Life doesn't work that way, and often sitcoms do work that way, but not this one, and I'm proud of that.
生活不是这样的，通常情景喜剧会那样处理，但这部剧没有，我为此感到骄傲。
Yeah, you guys were trying to inject what you loved about long-form narrative and movies and books into a sitcom.
对，你们当时试图将你们所热爱的长篇叙事、电影和书籍中的元素注入情景喜剧中。
You were taking a kind of tried-and-true form and trying to update it, in certain ways.
你们采用了一种历经考验的经典形式，并在某些方面试图对其进行更新。
What happened last week happened last week?
上周发生的事就是上周发生的？
Happened last week, exactly, exactly.
上周发生的，没错，没错。
Um, I love when Robin said I'd already broken the ice with my cool pie fact.
嗯，我喜欢罗宾说的那句“我已经用我冷门的派馅饼冷知识打破了僵局”。
It almost feels like before Robin dated Ted.
这感觉甚至像是罗宾和泰德约会之前的事。
Did she have cool pie facts?
她以前有冷门的派馅饼冷知识吗？
Was that where we're Ted's fun facts?
难道那是泰德的冷门冷知识吗？
Like I mean, look, there are connections between these two.
我是说，你看，这两人之间确实有联系。
It lines up.
这说得通。
Ted would do a cool pie fact.
泰德就会讲冷门的派馅饼冷知识。
I liked Cripkeeper's dad.
我喜欢“幽灵故事集（Cripkeeper）”的爸爸这个梗。
I had already mentioned that.
我之前已经提过了。
I love Kobe's run when I don't remember all of them, but which she said, that is a truth fact.
我喜欢柯比的一段连珠炮，虽然我记不全所有的了，但她说的那句“这是一个事实真相”。
Yes, that is a truth fact.
对，那是一个事实真相。
That was a Greg Malinsism in the room.
那是编剧室里格雷格·马林斯（Greg Malins）的口头禅。
That is a truth fact.
“那是一个事实真相。”
I think he was stealing that from somebody.
我想他是从哪抄来的。
He like heard that in real life somewhere and said, we're going to say, but when Kobe says you are correct, sir, she's doing the Ed McMahon.
他可能在现实生活中的某个地方听到了这个说法，然后说：“我们要把这句台词用上。”但当柯比说“你说得对，先生”时，她在模仿艾德·麦克马洪（Ed McMahon）。
She's doing a Carcenio sketch, Ed McMahon, and we're just putting it.
她在模仿卡森秀里的艾德·麦克马洪，我们只是把它放进去了。
That's just a bunch of comedy writers loving, you know, Dana Carvey doing Johnny Carson and just throwing that in the middle of Robins, seeing the bully in the kitchen.
这只是一群喜剧编剧太喜欢达纳·卡维（Dana Carvey）模仿强尼·卡森（Johnny Carson）的表演，然后随手把它塞进了罗宾看到厨房里那个霸凌者的场景里。
Barney's meltdown is incredible.
巴尼的崩溃太精彩了。
Like, I've lost 10 pounds, my suits are wearing me.
比如，“我瘦了10磅，我的西装都在反过来穿我了”。
Oh my God.
我的天呐。
You're allowed to slap my face, sir, but you're not allowed to slap my mind.
你可以扇我的脸，先生，但你不能控制我的思想。
I said good day, sir.
我说今天天气真好，先生。
I say good day.
我说今天天气真好。
Did he add, I said good day, sir, or was that in there?
他后面加上了“我说今天天气真好，先生”吗，还是本来就有的？
No, I think we had a thing for that.
不，我想我们当时专门加了句这个。
We were, that was a shiny toy in the writer's room, I think.
我们在编剧室里把这当成了一个亮眼的招牌，我想是的。
Yeah.
是啊。
Yeah, and just ending on friendship as an involuntary reflex, I, again, I just, I was always honored to be on a show that would say stuff like that.
是啊，最后以“友谊”作为一种非自愿的条件反射收尾，我再次觉得，能参演一部会说出这种台词的剧，我一直感到很荣幸。
That's cool.
太酷了。
My memory of breaking that episode, like I think I was, that was a me week, I think that episode, but Carter went off and wrote the song, you know, it was just the perfect division of labor.
我记忆中构思那一集的时候，好像那是属于我负责的一周，我想那一集是这样的，但卡特去写了那首歌，你知道的，这真是完美的劳动分工。
It was like, I was sort of doing that episode with Matt Coon in the writer's room.
这就好像，我在编剧室里和马特·库恩一起创作那一集。
Carter was doing this amazing song and just making sure that was amazing and doing that That was seagull.
卡特在写那首惊艳的歌，确保它完美无缺，然后做了那个……那是海鸥。
It was just like everyone was doing their thing.
就好像每个人都在做自己擅长的事。
And I remember reverse engineering the story from that, my favorite.
我记得是从那首歌开始反向推导故事的，这是我最喜欢的方式。
The thing I wanted the story to be about is that line, Josh.
我希望故事所围绕的核心就是那句台词，乔什。
I wanted it to be involuntary friendship and like, how do we get there?
我希望那是被迫产生的友谊，然后就想，我们该怎么做到这一点？
And for the thing, I will give Alec Angel credit.
至于这个点子，我要归功于阿莱克·安杰尔。
The thing that really sparked it was made for General Colonel.
真正激发灵感的是那个“为总司令制作”的梗。
It was all that stuff.
全都是这些内容。
That was it.
就是这样。
And I said, if we can use that, and that's what's gonna be the through line of the whole episode.
我说，如果我们能用上这个，这就是贯穿整集的红线。
And I'm very proud of how I came out.
我为我们最终呈现的效果感到非常自豪。
Writers listening, which I know a lot of writers listen to the show, because we talk about process a lot.
正在收听的编剧们——我知道有很多编剧都在听这个节目，因为我们经常讨论创作流程。
Starting, like getting the ending that is like incredible and working towards it is a good writer trick.
一开始就定下一个不可思议的结局，然后朝着它去努力，这是一个很好的编剧技巧。
You know?
你知道吗？
Sometimes your story will demand it be something by else by the end.
有时候你的故事发展到最后，会要求走向完全不同的方向。
But we started, even if you end up going somewhere else with it, but often you end in that spot.
但我们从一开始就这样做，哪怕你最后走向了别处，但通常你还是会落脚于那个点。
If you know that's good and you know that is where you will stick your landing, that's where you're sailing towards, it's so great.
如果你知道那个点很好，知道那就是你能稳稳着陆的地方，那是你扬帆起航的方向，这就太棒了。
And you also know that that's where you want the chess piece to move to set up the next story.
而且你也知道，那正是你希望棋子移动到的位置，以便为下一个故事做铺垫。
Yes, that's my favorite way to break a story is to know what that core thought is, what you're really saying, what it really has to get to.
是的，我最喜欢的创作故事的方式，就是明确核心思想是什么，你真正想表达的是什么，故事最终必须要达到什么高度。
And then it's fun reverse engineering to get to that moment.
然后通过倒推的方式来达到那个时刻，这非常有趣。
It's almost like you could almost write the narrator Ted's final thought and then we're back.
这就好比你几乎可以先把旁白泰德的最后感悟写出来，然后我们再倒叙。
Yeah, and how great is Saget to Bob Saget, another great Bob, two great Bobs in this episode.
对啊，萨吉特——鲍勃·萨吉特，又一个伟大的鲍勃，这一集里有两个伟大的鲍勃，他有多棒啊。
Bob Saget doing that narration is very moving.
鲍勃·萨吉特配的那段旁白非常感人。
We've also lost him since the show, and I'm just finding re-watching this, Josh, that Saggot was just such a secret weapon of the show.
自从这部剧结束以后我们也失去了他，重温这一集时我发现，乔什，萨吉特简直是这部剧里的一张王牌。
His narrations are so lovely and heartfelt, and there's humor and wisdom.
他的旁白那么优美、真挚，既有幽默感又充满智慧。
The sound or the timbre of a voice is so important, especially when it's only the voice.
声音的质感或音色非常重要，尤其是当它只剩下声音的时候。
And there's something, you know, the show starts and it's just like stock footage of New York, and you hear Bob snark on something.
而且你知道，剧集刚开始时只是纽约的资料画面，你听到鲍勃对某些事进行辛辣的吐槽。
You just feel like you're in good hands.
你就会觉得一切尽在掌握。
You're in good hands.
一切尽在掌握。
You feel very good hands.
你会觉得一切都稳了。
Yeah, it's a great time.
对，这是一段美好的时光。
Shout out to us.
向我们致敬。
I also, I'm just really enjoying watching this show again.
另外，我也真的很享受再次观看这部剧。
I hope that people are re-watching it with us or just enjoying this walk down memory lane.
我希望大家能和我们一起重温，或者只是享受这趟回忆之旅。
I did want to say one other thing to just close out this segment.
在结束这个环节之前，我确实还想说另一件事。
We started off with a disagreement, if it was Alec or Joel who came up with this joke.
我们一开始对这个笑话究竟是阿莱克还是乔尔想出来的意见不一。
I thought, you know, there's a thing in this episode which is, no, you did that.
我以为，你知道，这集里有个情节是，不，是你先那样的。
No, you did that.
不，是你先那样的。
who kissed to.
到底是谁先亲的。
Yeah.
对。
And when I watched it, I was like, I thought Kobe and I did that as well as you could have, because you cannot tell who starts.
当我看到这里时，我觉得，我和科比把这部分演得不能再好了，因为你根本分不清是谁先开始的。
You cannot tell.
你根本分不清。
Yeah.
对。
It's actually very rock and roll.
这其实非常摇滚。
Very organic.
非常自然。
It's very organic.
Very good.
非常好。
You guys are so good together in this one.
你们两个在这集里的配合太棒了。
And you guys are always good together.
而且你们俩的配合一直都很棒。
But you have to play like 75 different emotional beats in 21 minutes while there's fucking slaps and old guys and songs happening and it doesn't feel like your guy's emotional story is short-shrifted in any way.
但你们必须在21分钟内演绎大约75种不同的情绪起伏，其间还夹杂着该死的扇耳光、老头子们以及各种歌曲，可你一点也不会觉得你们的情感故事被敷衍了事。
Nor does it feel like we have to cut through the noise by amping it up.
也不会让人觉得我们必须要靠提高音量来盖过噪音。
It felt like we really trusted.
感觉我们真的很信任彼此。
I really love the scene in Ted's bedroom between the two of them.
我真的很喜欢泰德卧室里他们俩的那场戏。
Me too.
我也是。
It's heartbreaking.
太虐心了。
It's really angry.
真的很生气。
It's really angry and they're really ending it.
真的很生气，而且他们是真的要决裂了。
I was on the edge of my seat.
我当时看得心都提到嗓子眼了。
Like no one's at their best, but they're kind of at their best.
就好像每个人都不是在最好状态，但又某种程度上达到了最佳状态。
Like it's weird.
感觉怪怪的。
Yeah.
对。
So it's a good one.
所以这是一集很棒的剧。
Well, this was a great episode.
嗯，这一集太棒了。
I really enjoyed talking about it.
我真的很喜欢聊这个。
We're going to talk I want you to get in a room with Joel and just work this out and you're going to come back to us we're gonna Yeah, I don't know what's gonna happen.
我们待会儿要聊……我希望你能和乔尔进一个房间，把这事解决掉，然后你再回到我们这里，我们……好吧，我不知道会发生什么。
You're gonna find a way to work this out I just want to have one nice lapsgiving with you guys.
你会找到解决办法的，我只是想和你们一起过一个美好的感恩巴掌节。
There's a kernel of truth in each of your stories Have reached the part of the show we call the sea blog Who came up with this joke but Joel, this was all Joel.
你们每个人的故事里都包含着一丝真相，我们已经来到了节目中被称为“听众留言”的部分。究竟是谁想出了这个笑话？但乔尔，这全都是乔尔的点子。
This is Joel's, yeah, this is Joel's.
这是乔尔的，是的，这是乔尔的。
We've had a great time talking about Slap's Giving, episode nine of season three.
我们聊得很开心，关于“感恩巴掌节”，第三季第九集。
We're having a great time every week on this show.
我们在这个节目里每周都过得很开心。
If you are enjoying this podcast, please subscribe, tell your friends.
如果你喜欢这个播客，请订阅，并告诉你的朋友。
We would love more how I met your mother fans to be listening.
我们希望有更多《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝来收听。
There are more how I met your mother fans out there than our listeners of this show.
世界上《老爸老妈浪漫史》粉丝的数量，其实比我们这个节目的听众还要多。
We can assure you of that.
这一点我们可以向你保证。
But if all of the How I Met Your Mother fans in the world listen to the show, we would be Joe Rogan.
但如果全世界的《老爸老妈浪漫史》粉丝都来听这个节目，我们就是乔·罗根了。
I mean, we'd be more popular than we'd be like.
我的意思是，我们会比现在更受欢迎，就像……
We'd be the most popular podcast in the world.
我们会成为世界上最受欢迎的播客。
So we'd like to get, we'd like to approach those heights.
所以我们很想达到、很想接近那样的高度。
So please let your friends know.
所以请让你的朋友们知道。
Also, if you're loving this show, as you know, we often play an audio clip at the beginning from a fan of the podcast or the show.
另外，如果你很喜欢这个节目，如你所知，我们通常会在开头播放一段来自播客或剧迷的音频剪辑。
We read letters in this last section.
我们在最后一部分会阅读信件。
So please go to how we made your mother.com, H-W-M-Y-M, go up to contact Alec, built this website on Squarespace and follow the directions, they're quite simple.
所以请访问 HowIMetYourMother.com，简写是 HWMYM，找到联系我们页面——这个网站是阿莱克用 Squarespace 搭建的——然后按照说明操作，非常简单。
But let us know how the podcast is landing on you, what how we met your mother means to you, we'd love to hear from you.
但请让我们知道你对这个播客的感受，《老爸老妈浪漫史》对你意味着什么，我们很想听到你们的声音。
And today we have a great letter that Craig is gonna read.
今天我们有一封很棒的信，将由克雷格来朗读。
Yes, and I wanna add, if you're DM'ing me or Josh a cool story or a cool message, please also send that cool story or message to Alec and to what weird Josh just said, because if it comes to Josh and my DMs, we might not get to it.
是的，我还想补充一点，如果你正发私信（DM）给我或乔希一个精彩的故事或信息，请同时也把这个精彩的故事或消息发给亚历克（Alec），以及刚才乔希所说的内容，因为如果是发到我和乔希的私信里，我们可能没时间看。
And I sometimes discover them way after the fact, and so please send the messages to the podcast.
而且我有时是在事后很久才发现这些私信，所以请把消息直接发给播客。
And by the way, also, if you worked on the show, and you're listening, we know a lot of people that worked at the show were listening, we'd love, love, love to hear your stories, and please send them in as well, you can contact any of us however you want to, or just to go on there and please tell us about your time.
顺便说一句，如果你曾为本剧工作过，并且正在收听节目——我们知道有很多剧组工作人员都在听——我们非常、非常、非常希望能听到你们的故事，也请把它们发给我们。你可以通过任何你喜欢的方式联系我们中的任何人，或者直接去那里跟我们聊聊你当时的经历。
And if you're a friend of Alex, I'm on a steel credit for something He came up with, please also send those in.
如果你是亚历克斯的朋友，我在某个他想出来的点子上有署名权，也请把那些内容发过来。
Here we go.
我们开始吧。
From Harrison in Alabama.
来自阿拉巴马州的哈里森（Harrison）。
Hemium, I love this letter has a title.
“海姆ium”（Hemium），我喜欢这封信居然还有一个标题。
Hemium, a reflection through the years.
“海姆ium：岁月的倒影”。
Respect Harrison for putting a title.
向给文章起标题的哈里森致敬。
I've watched how I met your mother several times now, starting in my late 20s.
我已经把《老爸老妈浪漫史》看了好几遍了，从我快二十岁的时候开始。
Each rewatch has felt like a time capsule, bringing back memories of where I was in life and how the show resonated with me differently each time.
每一次重温都感觉像是一个时间胶囊，唤起了我对当时生活状态的记忆，以及这部剧在不同阶段是如何与我产生共鸣的。
The first time I watched it, I was in the thick of my single phase.
我第一次看这部剧时，正处在单身生活的深水区。
Barney, for better or worse, became a kind of misguided inspiration.
巴尼（Barney），不管好坏，都成了一种被误导的灵感源泉。
His boldness gave me the push I needed to step out of my shy, late bloomer shell.
他的大胆给了我需要的推力，让我走出了害羞、大器晚成的外壳。
Whether it was at bars, airports, gyms, or even once at a marathon, I felt his spirit urging me to take chances and not fear rejection.
无论是在酒吧、机场、健身房，甚至有一次在马拉松比赛中，我都感觉到他的精神在敦促我抓住机会，不要害怕被拒绝。
Looking back, I did plenty of things I wouldn't repeat, but I don't regret them.
回想起来，我做了很多以后不会再做的事，但我并不后悔。
That era shaped me into who I am today.
那个时代把我塑造成了今天的我。
Years later, in my mid 30s, I re-watched the show and found myself connecting with Ted.
多年后，在我三十岁出头的时候，我重温了这部剧，发现自己开始和特德（Ted）产生共鸣。
I was ready for something deeper, but couldn't seem to find the one.
我已经准备好迎接一段更深厚的感情，但似乎总找不到那个对的人。
I even revisited past relationships, wondering if maybe it had just been bad timing the first time around, but I learned that love doesn't operate on a schedule.
我甚至重新审视了过去的感情，纳闷当初是不是只是时机不对，但我懂得了爱情并不是按时间表运作的。
It shows up when it's meant to, not when we expect it.
它在注定的时刻出现，而不是在我们期望的时候。
Now, as I near 40, and watch the series again, this time with my wife, I find myself drawn to Marshall and Lully.
现在，当我临近四十岁，再次观看这部剧时，这一次是和我的妻子一起，我发现自己被马歇尔（Marshall）和莉莉（Lily）吸引了。
Their partnership isn't perfect, but it's full of grace, forgiveness, and unwavering support.
他们的伴侣关系并非完美无缺，但充满了优雅、包容和坚定不移的支持。
Watching them reminds me of what I strive to bring to my own marriage, kindness, humor, and the courage to weather life's ups and downs together.
看着他们，让我想起了我努力为自己的婚姻带来的一切：善良、幽默，以及共同经受生活起伏的勇气。
Who knows?
谁知道呢？
Maybe the next time I watch it, I'll be a parent.
也许下一次我看这部剧的时候，我已经成为父母了。
And I'll find a new meaning in the show once again.
然后我会在剧中再次找到新的意义。
I could go on about how much this series and the podcast means to me.
我可以滔滔不绝地讲这部剧和这个播客对我的意义有多重大。
Thank you for creating something so heartfelt, hilarious, and real.
感谢你们创造了如此走心、搞笑且真实的作品。
It's more than a show.
它不仅仅是一部剧。
It's a companion through life stages.
它是陪伴我们度过人生各阶段的伙伴。
And for that, I'm endlessly grateful.
为此，我感激不尽。
That was great, Harrison.
写得太好了，哈里森。
Thank you.
谢谢你。
You know, it really speaks to something we say on the show that, you know, art, if it's good art, and I think we made some good art here, it changes as you change, you know, you enter it at different.
你知道，这真的印证了我们在节目中常说的一点：艺术，如果是优秀的艺术——我觉得我们这里确实创作了一些优秀的艺术——它会随着你的改变而改变，你知道，你在不同的阶段切入它……
He took us through it.
他带着我们走过了这一切。
He took us through exactly that process.
他完美地带我们重温了那个过程。
I love that letter for that reason.
正因如此，我非常喜欢这封信。
It reminded me of, you know, the evolutionary picture of, like, the ape turning into the human.
它让我想起了，你知道的，比如猿人进化成人类的那种演变图。
But it feels like there's stages of, let's just say, a man's life, you know, where, you know, you're trying to.
但它感觉像是涵盖了男人一生的各个阶段，比如说，你在努力……
You know, you're trying to get out.
你知道，你试图走出来。
I liked how he honored that the part of him that was like a Barney was trying to get over his shyness and his discomfort.
我喜欢他向自己体内那个曾经像巴尼一样的部分致敬，那个试图克服羞怯和不适的自己。
Yeah, that was a nice mention of Barney.
是的，对巴尼的那个提及真不错。
I haven't quite heard it exactly like that.
我以前没怎么听到过这种说法。
Barney made me get out of my shell to try to be a little bit absurd at times.
巴尼让我走出了自己的壳，尝试在某些时刻表现得有点荒谬。
And I needed that cartoonishness for two seconds to right bloom or something.
我当时需要那种漫画般的特质两秒钟，好让自己开窍什么的。
There's something nice about that.
这种说法有一种很棒的美感。
Yeah, it's like the virtuous side of Barney.
对，这就像是巴尼善良的那一面。
And then as he got older, he said, Oh, I'm actually more interested in like connection intimacy.
然后随着他长大，他说，“哦，我其实对人与人之间的连接和亲密感更感兴趣。”
And I would love to meet someone.
“而且我很乐意去认识某个人。”
And I like how there was just the thing now alongside my wife, like just dropping that in like, oh, I got married.
我喜欢他顺便提到“现在和我的妻子一起”的那种感觉，就像随口一说“哦，我结婚了”。
And then Marshall Lilly, like, if you're completely far from marriage, children, you know, cohabitation, Marshall Lilly are not going to land on you as much.
然后是马歇尔和莉莉，如果你离婚姻、孩子、同居这些还很遥远，你知道的，马歇尔和莉莉是不会对你产生太大触动的。
But once you get in that, like they're your peeps, you know, they're your people, like they're your North star.
但一旦你步入那种生活，他们就是你的同道中人，你知道的，他们就是你的人，就像你的北极星一样。
They are your Now you're rooting for them.
他们就是你的……现在你在为他们加油。
Yeah, I also just want to say we, I've talked a lot about attachment theory just because it fascinates me, but like, you really can mark again the evolution of Barney as an avoidant personality.
对，我也想说，我们讨论过很多关于依恋理论的话题，纯粹是因为它让我着迷，但你可以再次清晰地标出巴尼作为回避型人格的演变过程。
Ted is an anxious, uh, a catcher and Marshall and Lily are securely attached.
特德是焦虑型，呃，一个追寻者，而马歇尔和莉莉则是安全型依恋。
So you really get this kind of, um, it's complete.
所以你真的能感受到这种，嗯，它是完整的。
It's complete.
它是完整的。
It's a real art.
这是一件真正的艺术品。
Yeah.
对。
Well, I love that letter.
总之我很喜欢这信。
That was great.
太棒了。
Thanks Harrison.
谢谢你，哈里森。
from you so keep them coming and keep them coming and listening and if you have any information about whether it was Alec Cordjol with the major general corporal colonel Joe.
来自你的来信，所以请继续发给我们，继续收听，如果你有关于到底是亚历克·科尔乔尔（Alec Cordjol）还是少将下士上校乔（major general corporal colonel Joe）……
Alec Aspenella please.
是亚历克·阿斯彭拉（Alec Aspenella）吧请。
Right in.
写信来吧。
We need to solve this.
我们需要解开这个谜题。
Thanks for joining us and we'll see you next time.
感谢收听，我们下期再见。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》由乔希·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人。
And it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
本节目由 Office Ladies 网络和 Audacy 呈现和发行。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
本节目的执行制片人还有珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西，节目由我、亚历克·莱夫制作和剪辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our Gen Z Masters are digital content producer Emily Blumberg, an associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是来自蓝色之点工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯，我们的 Z 世代大师是数字内容制作人艾米莉·布隆伯格，以及助理制作人凯瑟琳·格罗夫。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面艺术由约翰·莫罗创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
这对于帮助传播节目真的很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔希·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》，附加音乐由克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萨姆·西博尔德和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
请在 Substack 上订阅乔希·拉德纳的缪斯通讯（Muse Letters），并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐及其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, And read his other published writing at CraigThomasWriter.com.
在各大书店购买克雷格·托马斯的长篇小说处女作《事情可不是这样的》（That's Not How It Happened），并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上阅读他发表的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own dead father's society on Substep.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的“死去的父亲协会”（Dead Father's Society）。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解本节目为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的持续活动如何带来改变，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”（Make a Difference）标签页。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，他会跳舞。